okay
brilliant okay we are
good to go everyone so hello everyone
thank you very much for
joining us today my name is jackie
lawrence
and i'm one of the career coaches here
at udacity today's webinar is all about
transitioning your career during covid
19. i'm joined today
by my co-support mira who will be
assisting me with managing
with this webinar and the chat room
we've got quite a lot of material to get
through today
so let's get right into the detail
so moving on to the next slide okay
this is just a bit of background about
me so some of you
may know me some of you may not and
basically my role is twofold so i'm a
career coach and i'm also a business
strategist
as a career coach i provide career
coaching to
individuals looking to transition to a
different role maybe you're looking to
change profession
or step up a level you may also be just
simply looking to explore
alternative career options as a business
strategist
i help small business owners and
entrepreneurs to get clarity around
their goals
objectives and processes for their
business so that they can reduce
risk and inefficiencies in their
processes and their operations
achieve growth and take their business
to the next level
prior to working as a coach i worked for
15 years
in the corporate banking regulatory
service sectors as a lawyer supporting
and
advising individuals from junior level
to senior management on various
regulatory corporate and banking issues
so that's just a little bit of
background on me
um i guess the other thing if you
haven't guessed already from our private
chat is that i'm located in london
so i'm in the uk where and when i'm not
working what do i like to do well i love
traveling
obviously not much of that happening at
the moment
um those of you who are in london we're
probably fellow sufferers or those of
you who are in the uk actually because
we're going through our second
phase of lockdown at the moment so i'm
not much tooing and throwing unless
in sexual purposes i also enjoy doing
korean yoga
um also known as brain power yoga now
and participating
in charity events so let's move on to
our next slide
and this just sets out the agenda we
will be covering today so i'm not going
to dwell on it
because we're basically going to be
going through it all
um as we work our way through this
webinar so
let's move on to the next slide and this
is going to be poll time okay
so i'd like to kick off this session
with a poll um
and really this is all about
understanding
your reason for wanting to change
careers okay
so what is your reason um for wanting to
change careers
okay um if you just give me a
minute out on so that i can launch this
poll
for you where is it gone that's not
letting me
it's the pokemon
where's it gone great okay i'm about to
launch it to you so what's your main
reason for seeking a career change
is it because you are stuck in a job
that isn't you
um it's because you don't get on with
your team or manager
is it because you have a passion that
you want to pursue and you feel
now is the right time to pursue it are
you having to
pivot due to the pandemic or has your
focus
change and you're seeking a better work
life balance
so these are some of the reasons people
decide to
seek a career change and i'm interested
to know which of these
um is your reason for seeking a career
change okay so i'm about to launch the
polls hopefully you can see that now
okay so i'll give you guys a minute to
let me know what's your main reason for
seeking a career change
stuck in a job that's not you you don't
get on with your team
or manager you have a passion you want
to pursue
pivoting due to the pandemic or your
focus has changed
and you're seeking a better work life
balance
so let's go right okay great the poles
are coming
in we're at 70 which is great
okay this is good this is good looking
interesting
okay i'll give it a bit longer because
we're still at 70 percent
a couple more of you to vote
yeah this is this is an interesting
mix actually
okay let's see 77 that's great
come on almost end of the minute if we
can at least get it up to
80 or above 80 so that we get a fair
um proportionate response that would be
great
yeah 88 fantastic
okay five more seconds in case anybody
else
wants to put their vote in and then we
will look at the results
okay five okay i
am going to end the poll oh
there's been a selection ah fantastic
100 okay
let's go i can end the poll now
brilliant okay so
the results are in okay
so what's your main reason for seeking a
career change
well 33 of you said because you're stuck
in a job that isn't you
33 of you also said it's because you
have a
passion that you want to pursue
22 percent said your focus has changed
so you're seeking a better work-life
balance
11 is due to pivoting due to the
pandemic and what's interesting
nobody so nobody said it was because you
don't get on with your team or manager
so i'm just quickly showing the poll
results there so you can all see
all right so um that's interesting so um
sucking a job that isn't you is a very
common reason and having a passion that
you've always wanted to pursue
and then thinking listen now is that now
is the right time and particularly
um with the environment that we're in
okay the uncertainty of the pandemic
has got a lot of people thinking so um
totally understandable
why we probably got these results so
great thank you very much for
participating
in that i'm going to stop sharing that
now
it's good and now we can
move on to our next slide
okay so our next slide is all about
evaluating
your current position so having to work
remotely as a result of covert 19 has
given many of us an opportunity to
reflect
on what we really want out of life in
our career for some of you who have
unfortunately been made redundant as a
result of the crisis
this has probably put you in a position
where you are having to pivot your
career
um you may have been very happy with
what you were doing and unfortunately
due to
current circumstances you are now in
this position where you're having to
rethink what am i going to do
um where do i want to go how am i going
to get there
making career change of course is and
can be very rewarding
however many people view the whole
career change process as quite an
upheaval
in their life and it can be um it can be
a daunting process
and you know it does take time it does
take effort to make the switch
but the whole process and the way you go
about it really doesn't have to be
daunting
it's just about understanding and being
clear on what steps you need to take
to enable you to get you from where you
are now to where you really want to be
in terms of your career
one of the first things that you really
need to get clear about is
your big why so why are you wanting to
change careers okay
is it because you want to escape where
you're currently working
possibly due to a toxic company culture
maybe you don't get on with your team or
boss
looks like nobody's in that category
here or maybe you want to get out of the
industry you're working in
it could be that you've gone as far as
you can in your current role and you
feel like you're unable to progress so
you feel the only option you have is to
shift out and do something different
if you're feeling the link to your
current place of work then maybe you
need a role change rather than a career
change
so you could explore doing a similar
role in a different industry
or another organization that may be a
better fit for your values and
personality
this still has its challenges but not to
the extent of making a complete career
change
if your job has been severely impacted
because of the pandemic
or you want a role that enables you to
earn a higher salary
or you have a passion that you've always
wanted to pursue and feel
that now is the right time for making a
change then you probably are looking to
go for a complete
career change if you've made a decision
to do a complete career change
then you need to carry out some thorough
research to ensure that the change you
make will take you in the right
direction
you could start off with a brainstorming
session where you consider your
personalities
your skill your values and interest
there are some self-assessment tools
that can help you those of you who
sort of like to do self-assessment tools
around your personality traits and
these include myers-briggs and dis
profile assessment
and for those of you who aren't aware of
what this stands for its dominance
influence steadiness and consciousness
um and there are some other sort of
online ones some you have to pay for
some summer free
alternatively you can simply write it
all down so write down
what brings you greatest feelings of
fulfillment in life
and also think about those areas that
you know that
you dislike be honest with yourself when
you're carrying out this exercise
make a list of the careers you like the
sound of or careers you think
may use your strengths and expertise
start researching these areas these
career areas okay
you could start off by using the us
bureau of labor statistics site
even if you're not in the us you can
still use this because this is all about
finding out about the careers that
you're interested in generally okay so
this is not really
being really specific on pain things
like that you just want a general
understanding of you know what does this
particular role
involve what is it what does it mean
that i'll be doing on a day-to-day basis
um if you are aware of well-known
occupation information sites in your own
location
then by all means use those as a
starting point for your research
however for the purposes of this webinar
i'm just going to go
to show you how you can use the u.s
labor statistics sites for the purposes
of job searching okay
so let's move on to the next slide and
here you will see this
is um what the kind of
um the face of the us bureau of labor
statistics looks like
but where you personally are going to be
heading is you're going to be looking
to click on the publications tab at the
top
and that will then bring you into a drop
down menu and then you can go into
occupational
outlook handbook and then when you're in
that
page and on that page which is the page
that you see now you can then type in an
occupation that you would like to learn
more about
so for the purposes of this example i've
used web developer
and as you can see i've got two
screenshots and one
talks about what they do so what does a
web developer do and that gives you some
information about that
and the other site um slides sorry gives
you information on how to become one so
this is all about
the education the requirements that you
need to meet in order to become one
so that's just an example of a starting
point that you can use just to generally
and find out a bit more about careers
that pique your interests
so moving on to the next slide
this slide is also um reflecting the
euro
you us burial labor statistics but
in addition to the two screenshots that
you've seen
there's also another slide which is all
about
similar occupations so you may find an
occupation you may read about it you may
think
some of it's okay some of it's not okay
i'd like to do something similar but i
don't really know what i want to do
so you could click on the similar
occupations tab and what that does is
that throws up
similar occupations so since you're at
the investigation stage you might as
well
learn about similar roles and so on here
you can see it's listed the similar
roles
to web development that you may find
interesting if that's your field of
interest
so that's just a quick example of how
you can just use that particular site to
help you if you're at your very early
stage or if you've started something
um and you know start to sort of
transition on a career and you suddenly
get a feeling
i'm not really sure if this is really
the right route for me
let me think about other alternatives
and it just means you can do sort of a
quick
check back of other alternative careers
that might appeal to you
so let's move on to the next slide
okay and i have another poll for you
and before we move into the next section
i just wanted to get a general
understanding of whether
you have done any work around your
transferable skills
so now we're moving into the section
which you're talking more about now
you've identified the career
path that you want to go down and it's
all about um
how am i going to get there so this is
just a short
um quick hopefully poll for you so have
you done a review of your transferable
skills your options are yes recently
or it could be yes but it was a long
time ago or
no so i'm going to now um
click the poll oh mirror the
slide decks gone
hello mirror
i can't see the slide deck
it's back okay great thank you
okay everyone back to the poll i'm going
to launch it right now
okay and
here we go to next poll
here it is here you
go have you done a review of your
transferable skills yes recently
yes a long time ago or no i'm going to
give you guys a minute to quickly
click on what's relevant to you
okay interesting great numbers are going
up
we're at 55 let's see if we can get it
up up
okay great 66
come on guys keep voting we're getting
there interesting
and get a bit more see if we can get it
to at least 75
if possible
okay i'm gonna give you one minute so
we've got about 15 seconds left for
anybody else
who is going to vote
okay 10 seconds
okay i am going to end the poll there
okay so the results are in have you done
a review of your transferable skills
57 of you said no
29 of you yes you did do it but it's
been a long time ago
and 14 of you i'm gonna just share this
with you now
said yes recently so that's quite a lot
of you
um 57 who haven't yet carried out a
transferable skills
assessment 29 yes long time ago and we
do
you know our skill sets can change we
can improve increase on them so
you may want to um those of you who are
in that category that 29
you may want to consider reviewing
your transferable skill set and seeing
if there's any
additional skills that you've added
there may be some schools out there that
you didn't think about and as we go
through the next section
um this may trigger your mind those of
you who haven't done it
maybe a reason it may be that you're not
quite sure what you need to do to carry
out
so we are about to cover that and
hopefully you'll be able to then
move on and be able to do your own
transferable skills review so i'm going
to stop sharing that
now thank you very much everyone for
participating
in that and now we can
move on to the next slide which is all
about conducting
a skills audit okay um
so this is you know taking you on to the
next step in your
career transition process so basically
once you've decided on which career path
you want to go down
or you have at least narrowed it to two
or three options you need to think about
how are you going to get from where you
are now to where you want to be
and as part of your initial research you
should be aware of what qualifications
are required for your new role
however just because you don't have
experience of working in your new field
of interest
it doesn't mean that your current skills
are not valuable in that field
and this is why it's really important to
invest time in finding out what your
transferable skill set is
for those of you who aren't really sure
what transferable skills are they're
basically a set of skills and abilities
that can be applied to a range of jobs
and industries so effectively you can
take them with you wherever you go what
you're wanting to do here is get clarity
around
your set of transferable skills and one
approach you can use to assess this is
to make a list of your hard skills so
these will be your technical skills
so these will be things like you know do
you have experience of python or sql
html tableau whatever your hard tech
skills are
and then make a list of your soft skills
so these are things like your
communication skills your presentational
skills
your organizational skills so i mean
your presentations because your
organizational skills
your stakeholder management skills okay
so these tend to be skills which are
based around
behavioral skills or soft traits um
there's a lot that
goes into you know what amounts to
transferable skill
i'm not going to go into it in any great
detail
because my colleague mira actually did a
whole webinar series on transferable
skills a while back
and you can find the link to the webinar
on the udacity's youtube channel
in fact i think my colleague mira may
also be able to share that link with you
in the chat
so please do keep an eye out on the chat
she's probably going to share it in
there with you so that you can go away
and in your own time
and work through that then what you're
going to want to start to do is
you're going to start wanting to search
for jobs that appeal to you on linkedin
dice indeed whatever job board sites
that you prefer to use
okay you're going to want to pull off
two or three job postings and focus on
the job requirements
then use the job requirements to map
your existing skills
to the new position you could use a
skill mapping table to help you do this
and i've got
an example of one and that i tend to use
on the next slide
you're going to be looking for where
there is a crossover between your
existing skills
and the job requirements skills and then
you're going to
have to identify any skill gap
so let's move on to the next slide where
you will see an example of a
transferable skills mapping table
and i'll just quickly talk you through
this so you can see it's not a
complicated table it's just got a table
with five columns
your first column is where you're going
to list your hard skills so like i said
that's going to be
your python and any particular skills
that you've kind of gone off and had to
learn
and then you've got soft skills so as i
said again it's going to be your
communication skills your presentation
skills
your creative thinking skills all of
that goes into that category
then you're going to obviously look at
the requirements that are set out in the
job description and what specific skills
are they asking for
then you're going to list that there and
then you're going to do your crossover
so you're going to compare what's in the
middle column
to what you've written in the left hand
column so what you've written your hard
skills in your soft skill
are there any crossovers that you can
list in that middle column
okay sorry that you're going to list in
that column further to the right the
crossover skills column so you're going
to list them all there
then what you're going to look for is
your skill gaps okay so these are going
to be
those areas that you look at and you
think don't really know much about that
or maybe you know a little bit about it
but you wouldn't be able to feel
comfortable or competent at hitting
a job with it on day one so really these
are going to be your weaker areas
or your skill gaps you either have no
knowledge or very little knowledge
and certainly don't feel that it's
sufficient knowledge for you to be able
to do
a job involving using that particular
skill or expertise
that's the area that you're really going
to have to give some thought to because
you're going to have to think about how
can you close or mitigate that gap okay
does it mean you're thinking about going
off and doing another course to upskill
yourself in that area
could you probably do a couple of
tutorial bytes
online so you may be able to find some
20-minute tutorial bytes on edlern or
some of the other
online sites that provide tuition
alternatively you might want to think
about doing an open source project
so it may be a case of having to go on
to leak code hackerrank
or kaggle one of these other sites and
looking for an open source project which
means that
you will be using that particular skill
as part of that project
and will enable you to be in a position
at least if you were called up to an
interview
and that weakness was pointed out to you
you'd be able to evidence well this is
what i'm doing to try and close this gap
so really give some thought to those
gaps as you come
across them don't just think i'll learn
it on the job okay because that's not
really what a hiring manager wants to
hear at an interview
they want to see that you've made some
effort towards closing that skill gap
okay so let's move on to your next slide
now remember you are transitioning okay
so there's going to be a
whole load of things that you have in
your toolkit
that probably aren't seen as relevant to
the job
however that's going to be your
value-add you know
this is thinking about what will you
bring to your
new career in other words what can you
um promote as adding value to
at an interview or when you're filling
in an application form
again i've set out in table form because
sometimes it's easier
to gain clarity when you capture
information in a visual format
so here again you'll see again it's
another table it's not difficult
it's just setting out your specific
expertise so this is all about what
expertise do you
have okay um in the first column it's
about your work function expertise okay
so what are you really good at what's
your role currently now
what's your work function what do you do
okay then it's your subject
knowledge expertise yeah so this is all
about
you know your knowledge expertise what's
your area
hello
hello could i just ask you to go on mute
please
so thank you very much okay so
what can you bring again like i say to
your new career then you're going to
look at sector expertise
okay so what sector do you work in do
you work in finance
are you in a fintech are you in retail
are you in marketing
are you already working in telecoms or a
tech
sector okay your client group so do you
tend to work with b2b business to
business
or b2c business to customers is there
anything else that you think that
you could flag up as value add when
you're having these discussions
at an interview or you know even when
you're
sharing with someone who's already
working in that field
okay so this is not really thinking
about what do you bring to the table how
are you going to
pitch yourself and promote yourself and
sell yourself as you're making this
this transition your unique selling
points this is going to tie in with that
okay and so at the bottom all i've done
is just just put a link
so that you could actually find this
particular table okay because this is a
source that i use
so let's move on to the next slide again
i'm just going to quickly go past
this slide um this slide is just an
example of a transferable skills
checklist
and sometimes using one of these can
really help to trigger
your mind around all the different type
of skills you actually have
there are loads of them um and like i
said my colleague mira did
um a whole webinar on transferable
skills and
there's lots of additional sources and
there's a different
skills checklist tool in there so you
know you've got ample resources to sort
of really help you really nail down
your transferable skills you'll probably
be surprised when you look through a
checklist like this
and i know it's very small probably on
the screen so you can't see any detail
but you'll be surprised at the range of
things that are classified
as a transferable skill so i highly
recommend definitely looking
at these transferable skills checklist
going online pulling one off
and having a look through it because
there's probably a couple of things that
you've got
that you didn't realize were
transferable skills and hence you
haven't actually
um accounted for them or used them in
your application materials
okay so we'll go with that we're going
to move on to
our next slide and now what i'm really
wanting you to do is
share your thoughts okay so i'd like you
to share your thoughts on this one and
this is
all about when it comes to changing
careers what is your main concern
so please let me know by typing your
comments in the chat box
what's your main concern about changing
careers okay
yes it's exciting um you know to think
about embarking on this new journey
um and what it can bring for you and how
it can change your lifestyle
but at the same time we've all probably
got reservations when you're going down
that journey and i've made that
transition so i know there are
reservations
but i'd be interested to hear from you
all what what's
what are your concerns about making
a transition so i'll give you guys a
minute or so
just to please share in the chat
you know and this is not a judgmental
session this is just about
you know what is it that may concern you
because our next session is just going
to cover um
all around those barriers for making the
transition so those things that
tend to worry or concern people when it
comes to making
that change okay
so are you worried about
um how you will catch up are you worried
about
salary change what is it that's really
your your main concern
okay
okay all right
so thank you for that let's have a look
brilliant
okay thank you lack of skills leading to
early project failures okay that's a
that's a genuine
concern yeah the skills am i good enough
do i have enough skills
making up technical deficits due to
having a different educational
background yep
so you're switching from mechanical
engineering to cloud yeah that is that
quite that's quite a change
finding time to up skills you're
currently working yet
worrying about salary decrease yeah lack
of experience compared to others yep
comparing yourself to others
okay doing machine learning ai in
healthcare self-driving cars
more than eight years experience of web
development but i'm not sure i will move
to this new career and get a job yeah
you know the uncertainty in the job
market's a big one vishal
right now in particular now you've gone
down this journey
all right a lot of you have gone down
this journey and covert has bang
hit everyone um and there's no certainty
right it's really
uh it's really shaken up the employment
industry okay
um and yeah those those are all really
genuine concerns you know where
do i go from here um
yeah exactly sometimes people will be
telling you now is not the right time to
make a move
and ultimately at the end of the day you
will know whether that's
right for you okay only you can make
that
decision okay that's great guys thank
you very much for your contribution on
that that's really helpful to understand
um you know your your main concerns and
your thoughts and we're going to be
covering some of those now
so let's move on to our next slide
okay and as i mentioned before making a
career change can be very rewarding okay
but it also has its challenges
and it's likely that you will have to
make some sacrifices in order to
accomplish your goals
and of course each person's career
journey transition journey will be
different
okay so let's look at some of the
challenges people
generally face when switching careers so
one of the main challenges
is the transitioning period okay often
the transitioning period can take longer
than expected
the process is more like a marathon than
a sprint
so some of you may start the process and
then find
your career switch actually requires
more upskilling
than you initially thought so you end up
doing a masters which was what you
hadn't originally planned for
or you end up having to do a number of
courses off the back of your original
course
and so of course all of that elongates
the process
the main thing i would say to you here
is stick with the process
okay um try not to get sidetracked
obviously things happen in life that
means that we may need to put
it on hold our transition journey on
hold but
stick with the process yes it may take
you
a year um for some students i know it's
taken them two years but they
have actually ultimately at the end of
the day achieve their goals and their
dreams
so it's worth the wait often you know
it just makes the journey more
worthwhile when you get to the end of
that process and you finally made it
the other big barrier tends to be costs
right so in most cases switching careers
often means retraining or doing some
form of educational program
this can be expensive both in terms of
time and money
so you're really going to want to shop
around for courses look into doing boot
camps
any free courses that are available out
there grab them okay
be clear about how you will fund your
course
okay the worst thing is to start a
course and then get halfway through and
find that you've run out of funds so
really try and um think be forward
thinking think ahead
how are you going to fund this course
what happens if you need to do an
additional course
try and give yourself some sort of
buffer
again we look at time don't
underestimate how much time you will
need to commit to studying and job
searching
you may need to temporarily give up some
other hobbies in order
to make way for this so you should as
part of your
whole transition strategy be allocating
time
um specific time to really researching
for jobs that you want to do and apply
to
so let's move on to our next slide and
this is continuing on with considering
barriers for a career change
so for some of you switching careers may
mean taking a salary cut
particularly if you will be starting at
entry or junior level
so you need to weigh this up against
your financial commitment so your
current financial commitments
do your salary research so assess how
this would impact your financial
situation
there are a number of websites you can
use to help you do this
there's like glassdoor indeed salary.com
pay scale to name a few and i've listed
them as you'll see
on the slide so if any of you um would
like that give us a shout um
maybe myself towards the end at q a i
can copy and paste it into the chat
box or if myria has the opportunity she
may be able to do so
um towards the end also but yet make
sure you spend time
um on doing your salary research okay
that's really really important
so that you can know roughly get a rough
idea
of um what type of salary you will be
earning at the start of your
transitional journey when you first
start with a new company
then the next thing is there's your
mindset okay
some of you will really have to work on
your self-belief that's you believing
that you truly have the capability to be
able to make the transition
when you initially start mixing with
individuals
in your new field of interest you may
start to feel like an imposter
so for those of you who don't know what
imposter syndrome is it's a
psychological pattern where you have
feelings of inadequacy and doubt about
your skill
your talents or accomplishments despite
evidence
of your success you probably may be
feeling an internalized fear that at any
moment you could be exposed as a fraud
or a fake okay i'm not going to dwell on
it in any more detail because mira will
actually be doing a webinar
on this next week so she's doing a whole
webinar
all about imposter syndrome so i really
recommend that you attend that webinar
if that is something you want to know
more about
however when these thoughts come up what
i would say to you is that you really
need to stop and ask yourself
how are these thoughts serving you right
are they helping you to progress
or are they holding you back
the last point i want to mention here is
boundaries okay what are your boundaries
what do i mean by that
well some of you will be transitioning
because there are certain things about
your previous or existing career that
really made you unhappy
some of those things may have even
impacted your emotional well-being
so define your boundaries around what is
and is not acceptable to you in your
career
of course there's always give and take
and when you're starting a new role
um you may find that you know you're
having to do longer hours for example
than you would like in the initial phase
but if you know you're changing queers
because
you wanted a better work life balance so
that's something you really
value you're unlikely to want to take up
a role which will require you working
late nights and weekends
so really think about your core values
what's important to you
and if your new career or role is in
alignment with your core values
it really helps to make the transition
process much smoother one
let's move on to our next slide and this
is going to be the final poll
of the session so before we move on to
our next topic i'm interested to know
whether you have written a career
transition plan so do you have
a written career transition plan yes
number one
or two you started one but it's
incomplete no
i'm not sure what the steps are or is it
no
i prefer to wing it okay so let me know
i'm gonna launch this poll now
find a poll okay which one
are you okay do you have a written
career
transition plan yes you started one but
it's incomplete
no you're not sure what the steps are or
no i prefer to wing it and i've just
launched the pole so i'm going to give
you all
a minute to decide which option applies
to you
okay so which question
okay okay interesting
this one's really moving it's really
changing good keep going
fantastic we are at 90
brilliant okay
i'm going to give it 15 more seconds
since we're at 90
we're virtually there in case anybody
wants to put in
last-minute vote okay i
am going to end the poll
and share the results so as you can see
what
40 percent of you said no you haven't
yet done a written career transition
plan and that's because you're not sure
what the steps are and hopefully as we
go into the next section
that should all become clear to you um
thirty percent of you said you started
one but it's incomplete
okay and that's fine at least you you've
started to set something down in stone
so you're
thinking through the process 20 yes you
have that's fantastic
to those of you who already have and 10
no i prefer to wing it okay so that's
interesting
all right so let's stop sharing that
brilliant thank you very much for your
participation
in that poll and now we are going to
move on to
our next slide and this is all about
writing
a career action plan so this is all the
steps that you
um you know i recommend or i suggest you
go through okay
as you can see i've started the section
off with a
famous quote by benjamin franklin if you
fail to plan
then you are planning to fail okay
so what you're going to want to do is
you want to get it written
out in a way that makes sense to you
okay
so let's start going through this
transitioning careers is a significant
event
okay with lots of moving parts and
things to consider
and as with any major project you embark
upon
you want to have a plan okay some
logical structural steps that takes you
from point a to point b
now let's look at writing a career
action plan so i'm going to take you
through
one example of how you may want to
structure
your action plan or at least um some the
various points you need
to how to bring it all together so
ideally you should be allocating time
slots and timelines for completing these
actions in order to keep the process
moving okay so you know if you've got it
set out in terms of a timeline
it makes it um much more real the whole
process what you're visualizing
and you're able to kind of quantify your
progress to measure your progress
so like i say you start with the basics
identify your career switch
which career are you switching to so
ideally you're going to want to find
four to five websites where you can
research your career area
this could include sites like the us
bureau of labor statistics which is the
site i took you through earlier
if you're in the uk you might want to
use prospect
jobs ac dot uk there are alternative
sites you can use
you will as part of your own research
come across sites that you probably find
useful and very
helpful so i'd incorporate whatever you
find
um in terms of sites that you want to
regularly go back to
and consider your career option put them
all together in one particular place so
that you can
regularly dip in and out of those
particular sites job searching
okay so once you've nailed down the role
you want to switch to
try and allocate a regular time slot for
job searching and applying for roles
will it be one hour a week so it doesn't
have to be
you know a hefty time time frame because
appreciate
your working um some of you will have
families some of you may have
you know other activities that you're
committed to so this is all about
really being consistent that's the key
thing even if it's 30 minutes
a week just be consistent and keep that
30 minutes
for those of you who may be switching or
transitioning roles but also looking to
relocate abroad
you may need to take additional steps
like reaching out to recruiters
in that location to find out what's
happening in the job market in that
territory
particularly with what's going on with
coved okay
the main weakness for people who are um
trying to get a role abroad particularly
if you're not going to be going over
there first you're looking to find the
role first and then
move over there your main weakness is
you probably don't have people on the
ground
you're not on the ground and therefore
you're kind
of applying blindly into a
country for a role where you have no
real understanding of what the dynamics
of that job market
are so you're really going to want to
find people on the ground that you can
connect with
that can give you a better understanding
of what's going on in that job market
what's going on in that industry um
what's the employment situation like for
that particular role okay and that's
something that you're going to have to
keep monitoring
throughout your transition process be
specific with job title searches
a lot of um students i know will just
say you know say the role product
manager they just put in product manager
okay um there are lots of different
types of product managers for example
are you looking to be a technical
product manager are you looking to be a
business product manager are you looking
forward to being
a customer product manager an internal
product manager be
specific if you're looking for entry
level role pool
entry level product manager or junior
level
product manager as part of your job
search title in order to narrow down
what it is that you're really
looking for really getting specific
with the area and the focus if there's a
particular
industry you're interested in include
that so maybe you're doing you're do
you're applying um on an industry
targeted basis so you know i want to
work in finance or
i want to work in um marketing for an
advertising agency
then be specific about you know where
you
want to search for your roles okay
because time is of the essence and time
you probably don't have a lot of it so
you've got to use it wisely
so be aware of how covert has impacted
the economy which market sectors are you
talking like i said
if you have a list of target companies
you may want to apply to
a couple of them for example are
software vendors who clients are mainly
made up for business
says operating in a hospitality travel
and tourism or aviation industry
you will most likely have to rethink
which companies you want to apply to
okay because those industries have been
so heavily impacted the chances are
um you will either have to wait it out
if you're desperately wanting to just
work with those industries or you're
going to have to rethink which sector
market you're going to target
okay let's move on to our next slide
okay so this is all about application
material go through the job requirements
in details and show how your skills and
experience match up
to the role okay again you could use the
transferable skills mapping exercise we
went through earlier to help you do that
you're going to want to reach out to
your connections you could also do that
at the research stage so this is
you reaching out to anyone in your
network who is doing the job you want to
do
or if you have a close contact who can
introduce you to someone who is doing
that role
it's always better to find out front
what's it really like
working in that industry before you
yourself make that move
okay update your resume and linkedin
profiles you're going to want to start
tailoring your resume to your new field
of interest
the about me section in your linkedin
profile should reflect the direction in
which you want your career to travel
okay so you need to mention the field
you want to transition into
make sure you list all your competencies
and your skills and expertise in your
linkedin about me profile
let's move on to the next slide
and so sorry i'm speeding up a bit here
because we don't have a lot of time but
i want to make sure
um that obviously we cover everything
hence why i've sort of
sped up a bit okay so clean up your
social network so this is really
important
check your linkedin profile facebook
profile for
anything that may not hold you in a
positive light
so remember people can see your past
comments that you've made what you've
said
so really think about what have i said
how will this reflect on me
if a potential employer looks back at my
facebook page or they look at my
linkedin page and what i said
craft your new narrative so how will you
describe yourself during your transition
okay um when you're transitioning this
is all about your pitch
being ready to answer that question
what do you do and again what is your
unique selling proposition okay what's
unique about you and that's why it's
helpful to do that value add
exercise completing that table because
that will kind of get your thought
process thinking around
what's your unique selling point work on
crafting your narrative
so recruiters and hiring managers can
more easily connect the dots between
what you have done and what you want to
do you're also going to want to build up
experience alongside applying for roles
okay
if you're looking to transition
internally at your current workplace
think about whether you could apply for
an internal secondment or take a new
project that involves
using skills in your field of interest
volunteer if you can
could you get some of the skills
required um
for your new career in another sector
could you get it elsewhere
could you volunteer with a
not-for-profit organization to do some
sort of project which will enable you
to get that unique expertise that unique
project experience that you can put on
your resume
and it could potentially open other
doors for you
so let's move on to our next slide
so the next topic i want to talk to you
about briefly is networking so before i
do so i just want you to quickly share
your thoughts have you started
networking so have you started
connecting with people in your new
career field okay let me know by quickly
typing your comments in the chat box
have you already started connecting with
people
in your new field of interest
okay and i'm just going to spend
literally
one minute on this because i want to
i want to um move on quickly so anybody
have you started
networking
yeah and i've done a whole i'm not gonna
go into this in any great detail because
um some of you i don't know if any of
you were able to attend but back in
september i did a whole webinar on
networking strategies for your
um career advancement and mira has
kindly shared the link to that
in the chat room so um i'm not gonna
dwell on it and it goes into real detail
around
what you can do in terms of networking
so great
only accept new people on linkedin yes
so a fair number of you have started
some of you haven't
that's not a problem it's it's never too
late to start yes cloud architect who
works at the same jim as you that's
fantastic benjamin that's thinking
outside the box
yeah i mean it doesn't it doesn't have
to be
just online right if you happen to meet
people in the gym or
at a coffee shop or anywhere you you go
obviously there's not that much kind of
connecting face to face now due to covid
but if you have the opportunity to do so
then yeah definitely do so that's
brilliant that's great
okay thank you guys for sharing there on
that
so i'm to move things along quickly
because i want you to have some
opportunity for q a
so this is just about moving on to the
next slide which is all about tapping
into your
network so making new connections so
what i would say is avoid relying solely
on your existing network because your
existing network is likely to have a lot
of people
who actually do the same thing that
you're currently doing okay
so make an effort to connect with people
who work in the industry you want to
transition into
talking to people in your new career
field will help you to understand
much better how good a fit you are to
your new career
okay you can also ask for advice on how
you might get in how future employers
might view your experience
have a game plan so when you're
connecting to people think about
what are you hoping to achieve okay do
you want to have an informal
or informational interview with them
where you chat with them for say 20
minutes about
what's it like to work in their
environment what's their day-to-day
responsibilities and you'll have a
checklist that you go through of
questions
that you may want to ask them are you
hoping to get a referral
okay um think about having a game plan
in terms of how many people will you
connect with a week
are you gonna make an effort to connect
to three people a week so you might say
i commit to connecting to three people
in the industry i want to transition to
a week follow companies and thought
leaders on linkedin in the areas where
you hope to work
okay so this is all about building up
that knowledge
what's trending keeping abreast of
trends by following what thought leaders
are tracking okay so let's quickly move
on to the next slide
okay and that again is just me sort of
talking through searching for people on
linkedin
and doing the role you would like to do
i've mentioned that work
towards oh that was what i wanted to
mention um when you're connecting
do make sure that you're doing a
personalized connect request okay
um people like to feel valued and if you
know you're going to want to go out to
that person for an informational
interview at a later stage
you need to start building authentic
connections early on
um before you really want to ask those
questions okay it takes time to build
authentic
connections so start early and start off
on the right footing
join groups on linkedin and other social
platforms that cover your field of
interest
so join tech groups on linkedin
so if you're a product manager there'll
be product manager groups front-end
groups there's
you know groups for front-end web
developers web developers generally
data analysts there are so many specific
groups targeted at whatever field you're
in so
really um think about joining those
groups because it will help you to
be in that whole environment that you
want to be with people who are
like-minded
and it will also mean that um you can
identify people you want to connect with
right
so you may then start to build up to
commenting on their posts so
obviously when you comment on people's
photos you get um
a notification that you know they'll get
a notification that you commented
on their post and it really helps with
building up that authentic relationship
so let's move on to the next slide
and this is just about having a backup
plan okay so the final area
i just wanted to mention today sometimes
unfortunately things do not go to plan
okay and maybe your course funding falls
through
or the relocation abroad where you were
due to start your new career has been
put on hold or
for some other reason things don't go
the way that you had planned
and covered that mentioned before has
introduced a lot of uncertainty into the
job market
so for example if you're transitioning
into digital marketing and hope to join
an advertising agency
well the events industry has been
heavily impacted and companies have been
cutting
their marketing budgets right so this
has had a knock-on effect on the
marketing industry as a whole
and i know this has really had a heavy
impact in the uk
it has resulted in a number of job carts
and what has started happening is rather
than
looking to recruit digital marketing
assistants or experts
some companies have revamped these roles
and are now looking
for communication experts with
everything that is going on around covid
such as the lockdowns the important
thing is really to get timely
customer communications out so that's a
key concern for businesses
so if you are in the digital marketing
field or that's the area you want to
transition into
in addition to looking for digital
marketing roles think about searching
for comms roles
okay communication roles so be mindful
of changes in job titles okay sometimes
we have to think outside the box
if you're looking to transition to a
career industry which has been heavily
impacted by covid
you may want to consider these options
so should you continue working in your
current role
and push back your transition until
things improve in the meantime
you could keep building up your project
portfolio you may want to consider
changing your field of interest or
changing direction if so what
alternative careers could you consider
and so this is where your early stage
research around careers that
interest you could really help you when
it comes to finding something similar
that may be suitable
also should you pursue another role as a
stepping stone towards your ideal career
and then make the final transition at a
later stage so rather than trying to get
a product manager role straight away
you may want to go for a product owner
role for example
and then at a later stage look to make
that leap to a product manager
or instead of applying for data
scientist roles maybe
um in a particular industry you may find
that there are more roles available
for data analysts so maybe you may
decide actually i'll go for a data
analyst for
work as a data analyst for a year or two
and then look to make that leap up to
a data scientist role so let me just
quickly run through final slide
which is all about takeaway points so
i'm just going to
hurry through this so that we can do
probably five minutes q a
spend quality time evaluating your
position and what you really want to do
review your transferable skills and if
you haven't carried out a transferable
skills exercise yet i highly recommend
you do so
identify any skill gaps and how you plan
to close them
work through your main concerns around
changing careers costs
timing salary reduction create a career
transition plan
setting out the steps you will need to
take and of course
don't forget to work on building up your
new network
okay so that brings us to the end
okay of the webinar and we
um just have our last section which is q
and a
in case anybody's got any q a's at this
point in time
um i know it's sort of one minute past
two but we started a couple of minutes
late so if anyone's got any questions
please um
you know share them with us in the chat
box um
and we'll answer them
okay any questions anyone or are you all
happy i know that was probably a lot of
information to digest
um and you will get you will get um the
recording it will be sent to you
so that you can take your time and work
through it
and yeah so it is a lot to digest so you
know
feel free let me know if you've got any
questions that you want to
answer i'm just going to have a look in
the chat box
okay any questions ah
what are my thoughts on internships
okay benjamin can you expand a bit so do
you mean in terms of going for
internships
or anything more to add to that because
internships are great
yeah is that benjamin hi yeah hi this is
me um
yeah so yeah something that i'm looking
at right now as
uh an option as a way forward is
i think it would be difficult for me to
land a position at
a bigger company who is probably looking
for
computer science grads people who have
the traditional background
but it might be available to me to take
an internship at a startup
um that would be either unpaid or very
low paid
but would still be a first
experience in the industry so i wanted
to know what your thoughts are
on on a situation like that
and i think if you get an internship
opportunity that's great
that really is great and startups
startups aren't for everyone but the
good thing about startups
is that they often give you a lot of
responsibilities and you get to a
variety of things and so the learning
curve may be quite
steep but that's what you want okay you
want to get
as much as you can whether it's a six
month internship a year
you want to really go in there get as
much as you can and of course
people understand you're in an
internship right so you're more likely
to get more mentoring
because that's the good thing about
being on an internship and going in
as an intern people understand you're an
intern as opposed to
when you go in straight as a role people
kind of expect you to come in with this
experience you're not an intern
you're here you know as a fully
qualified person
so internships are great if you can get
that experience and sometimes you don't
know where that internship can lead to
okay
it gives you a chance to go in really
show your skills
treat the internship no different though
as if you're
actually employed full-time for that
yeah for me it's a job it's just it's
the first job yeah exactly exactly you
really
want to shine um and you know raise your
game there
definitely if you get that opportunity
definitely i know that a number of
people have unfortunately had
internships pulled
this year because of the whole covert
situation but if you have an opportunity
a window to get one
go for it all right thanks
okay does anyone else have any questions
if not i can we can end the webinar
there
yep so great mira thank you she's
mentioned ama
so tuesdays we have a weekly ama call so
you'll ask me anything
called um with the coaches that's on it
that's on a tuesday apologies
and of course i am going to be going
into the
um student hub now so all the careers
take
in turns during the week to um sit in
the student heart for an hour
so you can ask us any questions so i'm
going to pop over into the student hub
now
so if anybody's got any q a you can um
carry it over to there okay so i just
wanted to say thank you very much to
everyone for joining thank you for your
time
thank you for participating in the polls
and sharing your thoughts with me it's
been great to
have you here um contributing engagement
has been wonderful
thank you all thanks very much have a
great day
whatever time it is or evening depending
on where you are okay
thanks a lot take care bye